[Music]
uh
uh
it was just an above average day at the
white house
when your favorite president was
catching up on the news
when suddenly oh mr president there's a
deadly virus from china
taking american lives oh china
gross this sounds like a job for super
[ __ ]
super trump oh no
no oregato then the worst
possible thing happened oh no i've been
infected with the deadly china virus
from china
gross so the very strong heroic super
trump went to the hospital
some even thought the china virus had
defeated him
but on the third day he rose from walter
reed and the china virus cried
like a little infectious
[Music]
i'm slightly confused
[Music]
all right glad to be with you uh there's
an intro if our guest is still on the
line we'll be back with our drinking
game rules the hashtags
uh the promo codes but right now for a
little bit of pre-gaming we have the
very fetching always lovely
uh if she's there hopefully miss megan
kelly are you there
hey i'm here how you guys doing well not
so good now that i'm on a split screen
with you
and i have these thighs uh so i
appreciate you making
the time i feel totally underdressed i
gotta say i should have brought my a
game
well i appreciate it because you are
underdressed and uh i'm disgusted but
let me ask you this by the way your your
youtube is megan kelly and the twitter
is megan kelly she's been doing some
wonderful work which we'll get to in a
second also your exclusive interview
with tara reid because that's
incredibly relevant tonight but um megan
i wanted to ask you something as someone
who's debated uh sorry moderated these
debates in the past
uh specifically watched pence there on
stage
in person what do you expect to go down
tonight
um i think it's basically the
hippocratic of do no harm
right and uh especially if you're kamala
harris because they're winning
right they're ahead in in all the latest
polls by a lot
so she if i were her i'd want to be just
as quiet
and as meek as possible this is not the
time to come out and prove what a strong
woman you are
it's like i'm invisible and the more he
talks the better off i am it's fine i
don't have to say much
and pence you know he needs to be the
statesman sort of the yin
trunks yang and remind people that he
could be serious and he could be solid
and he's not going to be
you know the hands and the basket he's
going to be like the one that people can
count on in a time of you know crisis
and i think that's really all it is it's
about optics of him
seeming serious and like the adult in
the white house and her being like
i'm not even here it's all about trump
oh my gosh you got to go back to that
that's a slate article waiting to happen
megan kelly megan kelly says woman
should be meek
it's smart it would be smart i i think
joe biden did the right thing too but he
if i were him i would have been even
more silent at that last debate just
like
let trump be trump and let him remind
everybody that you know he does
things that are controversial and you
just be over there like oh me
i don't i'm just gonna sip my latte i'm
gonna eat my kale
whatever that's a horrible stereotype of
course which is not uh
accurate of all black slash indian
people um but i do did you just advocate
did you just advocate that uh vice
president pence do jazz hands is that
what i saw you do jazz hands like if
this is gonna stop
today trump gave that impromptu
statement at the white house and he was
out in front of the white house
and my kids and i were he had like the
full body shot and i mean if you just i
challenge you to put that on
and just keep doing everything he did in
unison with him
it was it was crazy it was like out of
hand yeah it's like he's doing it he's
just for your kids doing a sing-along
just follow the bouncing bum
um let me how would you grade and i know
this is tough for you megan because
you've worked with him um and obviously
now you do so much uh on your own at
youtube.com
megan kelly do you wanna say that.com
just youtube megan kelly
don't even push people there push people
to my podcast which i just like
okay tell us what was that so can you
say it one more time
go to the podcast and search for a megan
kelly show
oh very easy we kind of idiot proved it
so just m-e-g-y-n
kelly show and there will be then
subscribe
and it's banned so you shouldn't have
been a guest you should not have been
our precious
yes um how would you grade chris
wallace's performance with the last
debate because obviously there was a lot
of fallout
um where people didn't think he was i
don't think he was particularly unbiased
i don't think it was as bad as people
said i do think he
he stepped in to save biden which in my
opinion is not a very good look
so okay that's that's where i can defend
him on the stepping into save biden a
couple of times when he was on the ropes
because
as the moderator when the time is
ticking away and one candidate won't be
quiet or keeps interrupting
all you're thinking is holy [ __ ] i've
lost total control of this hour i'm not
going to get to this entire list of
questions
the debate is going to feel unfair
because i i needed to get to this part
so all you're really looking to do when
it's gone on too long is
shut them up so you can move on and so i
think a couple times he was just trying
to rap biden so
for trump and and by so he could just
move on and in an attempt to do that
he kind of quickly gave it to biden and
that wound up looking bad for chris
but i think the areas were the fair
criticisms of chris had to do with
how some of the questions were loaded
with information that was obviously bad
for trump
and not really fair to trump like you
know
you you wouldn't condemn white supremacy
and what happened to charlottesville and
you know it was sort of
written by somebody who had been
accepting the new york times headlines
which is not like him
yeah well you know i don't just think it
was would you condemn white supremacy
which donald
trump has done many times but saying
would you condemn white supremacy sure
sure uh the proud boys and listen there
are valid criticisms against the proud
boys namely i just don't like joining
large groups of people because i don't
like gangs but
white supremacy is not one of them i
mean the guy who runs it is a black
cuban right now so
that really that's one of those things
that americans who know about the proud
boys who
watch the interview go okay even if i
don't like the proud boys that was a
really
unfair intermingling of two separate
points but
uh forcing one answer i i mean honestly
i i like most people just assumed it was
some white supremacy group because biden
specifically threw it out when trump was
like name one
and i hadn't i mean i followed the news
and even i was like cowboys what do they
do i know there's so many groups it's
hard to keep track but they've gotten
the best press of their life the last
week right like that now it's like
everybody knows who they are
um but my own read of that moment with
trump was
he he chris asked him will you condemn
white supremacy and he says sure
and then what happens next he and biden
at the same time go
do it do it do it now now
in what what land does anybody think
donald trump is going to respond
well to that right he doesn't like to
look weak he doesn't like to be
controlled by other people he hates the
media he hates his opponent
and i think he was just sort of trying
to get like i'm not i'm gonna be your
little puppet
i said sure that's good enough let's
move on yeah you know i think that's i
think you're right so do it do it what's
this the children of the corn what of us
what uh go screw yourself
it's true it really he doesn't like
doing what people tell them to do and i
do think that it was
a pretty fair response and like when
you're a kid and you know you take dare
and they want you to like roll around in
the mud or whatever they want you to do
and they're like do it do it and then
you're suddenly like i don't like you
and i don't like this game and peace out
is that is that how girls play truth or
dare as roll around in the mud because
we had very different childhoods
uh it's it's disgust men are disgusting
i'm sure you're married to one
um so you know but our truther dare was
really bordering on criminal not
it was actually criminal not anymore
it's different now in 2020 you're not
allowed to even think about another
person
at all yeah always go with truth always
go with truth and then
just lie that's how you win that game
um why did i only learn this in my
fourth almost fifth decade of life
that's because girls are earnest right
girls mature
earlier and for some reason that
maturity comes with this idea that they
have to be honest and they'll get into
less trouble
we know that it's always better to not
get caught um
largely because we probably get our
asses beaten by our moms more than girls
and rightfully so let me ask you this
tara reid obviously sexual allegations
against joe biden and you had an
exclusive
interview we had you on the show when
that that happened um what do you think
about
uh was it nbc or abc running it
on their australian uh uh network and
australia yeah it was 60 minutes right i
always get 60 minutes and charlie rose
confused because i can't tell the
difference between fossils
so what do you um what's your read on
that and how much relevance do you think
it plays into any of this considering
that kamala harris
said she believed biden's accusers so
you know that
interview will have nothing to do with
anything tonight because it was in
australia
and and people aren't even watching you
know american 60 minutes as much as they
used to never mind the australian
version
um and i i do think a lot of people saw
that tara reid interview that i did
because i put on youtube but most people
just grabbed it all the television
networks grabbed it and it was actually
wound up being seen by way more than
people who watched 60 minutes we did the
numbers it's like almost 30 million
so they're aware of her the electorate
is aware of her
but the media has avoided that story
like a plague i mean like
like trump coughing uh all over the
white rose garden right now i mean they
are like no
tar read we don't want to talk about it
and i feel bad for this woman because
it took guts to come forward i mean
assuming she's telling the truth it
took guts to come forward if you assume
she's not telling the truth she at least
deserves a fair hearing
and we were lectured about that at
length during the brett kavanaugh
hearings
and they just wouldn't give her the time
of day so i don't think you're going to
get a tara read question
at any debate at all yeah no i i know
wishful thinking
um let me let me ask you this kind of
shifting pace there
uh because you mentioned brett kavanaugh
and kind of getting into the legal side
you obviously have a legal background
what do you think about the
declassifying right now with all the
sort of i guess
russiagate spy gate whatever you want to
call it at this point all of these
documents
um do you think that was planned as an
october surprise from from uh the trump
camp and is it too little too late do
you think it'll have any kind of an
effect or even i i don't suspect it'll
come up tonight
i i do think it was it was planned or it
was it was they knew about it and the
timing is not
a coincidence and it's probably not the
only thing to come out but i don't think
it's going to do anything
i mean you tell me the media outlet
other than maybe fox
maybe maybe even the washington examiner
i don't even
know if the journal will go with it uh
that's really going to pump that story
that the media is all in provide they
don't want to hear anything that's bad
for him
or good for trump their coverage thus
far has been 90
bad for president trump all along
negative about president trump so why
would they change this close out
from the election they're clearly dying
provided to win
yeah no i i think i think the only way
maybe it would be undeniable is if
something comes out where biden uh
knew about it as well and they would
have to ask him directly you know
something
sort of popped up in the the d class of
the uh documents that
no longer rejected steve remember what
happened with uh when
president trump made a a major step
toward
not achieving peace in the middle east
but a major step toward it
it was nowhere no they barely wrote
about it you would you wouldn't know
when he did anything i
actually follow the podcast the daily
that's the new york times
uh podcast every day and it's
interesting you know i like to keep an
eye on what they're doing what they're
saying
they've never covered it never once they
were talking about i don't know some
genocide some country nobody's ever
heard of
they never talked about the middle east
or what just happened like all right
well i'll wait what about uh hunter
biden's three million from the
uh moscow widow to do blow off sex
slaves hip bone so that pop pup in the
new york times podcast i don't listen
no they don't they i think they did a
defensive hunter biden
when that story first came out and i
haven't heard about hunter since then
you know they usually switch when
there's news like that to the pandemic
back to the pandemic which is the bad
story for trump
right and by the way i appreciate that
you do listen to the other side i
actually have always told people this i
listen to the most
biased liberal shows that i can because
that way at least i know what i'm
getting there isn't spin and that used
to be really i would watch o'donnell i
would watch matt
oberman when he was still a thing you
know the young turks erie slate and
salon
but now cnn suffices really cnn suffices
as a villain for msnbc
but the daily is maybe one from what
you're telling me that i should uh also
be
paying attention i like the daily
because i don't have to deal with those
personalities you just listed which i
have no desire to deal with and i'm
really not a consumer of their news
product news product and quotes
when i what i really do is try to read
read as much as i can from the left and
the right i go to realclearpolitics.com
every morning and
they've collected editorials from left
and right and if you put one on top of
the other on the same subject
a set of facts will emerge that you see
the two sides apparently agree on and
you walk away a little smarter
yeah uh i guess so by the way he's gonna
be a competition to you uh keith
olbermann apparently he'll be hosting
some espn uh
political show on youtube i don't i
don't know what kind of cosmic bunny
hole i jumped into
where keith olman leaves a news network
goes to a sports network
to only have them relegate him to the
online political news commentary on
their youtube channel but that's where
we are
he's an angry angry guy and like that's
not my cup of tea either
i don't i don't need more anger in my
life who's looking for more anger
right like he's just dripping with it i
remember i remember talking a funny
story about o'reilly
um i was talking to him one day and i
was saying you know would you ever leave
fox for another network
and he said sure he's like you know
paddy couldn't work out a deal here i'd
go to cnn
or msnbc this is here 10 years ago and i
said really i go
msnbc he said yeah i go they'd have to
fire old women first and he said
they'd have to set him on fire right
yeah and he would be delivering a
soliloquy while on fire i've never felt
such flammable content to these degrees
before
i don't believe that this is like all
right shut up and just burn
um uh i know that i did a fake
documentary on keith olbermann with it
was played by yours truly and he was
pissed i heard through the grapevine
okay megan kelly final prediction we do
have to get going here
who do you think comes out the victor
tonight and then plug your uh juicy
podcast one more time that is not the
daily i think i think mike pence is
going to do better i just do i think
he's a great debater he's
totally self-controlled he's articulate
he doesn't fumble for his words
and the only way you know she's gonna
really fall down and mess it up is if
she gets too loud
and too aggressive and calls too much
attention to herself i think she should
be quiet and let her boss keep winning
and he should be the smooth reassuring
second in command but she can do all
those things with one laugh
it's like it'll be like mystic pizza so
i don't know
it is the megan kelly show on podcasts
available apple android wherever pocket
meg
thank you so much for coming in we
appreciate it and thanks for lending
your expertise
thanks for having me what do you have
under that rope uh well you know this is
actually
i actually had regulation boxing shorts
and ted cruz was on the pre-game the
last stream and then i i didn't real i
realized that there's a reason boxers
don't wear those shorts
seated this way they're typically
standing in the ring so these are
actually the new and improved
but these are these are my hairy in my
hairy melting pot
scottish german irish thighs so
you're playing more where that came from
you play your cards right thank you
megan kelly
you are welcome we must go be well let's
go to the intro and come on in with the
drinking game rules
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah glad to be with you oh that was a
brilliant hopefully you get the sound
right better than that uh all right that
was
what is this
by the way really quickly it is crowder
debate stream the hash tag credit debate
stream if you go to louder with
credit.com
mug club you will get 20 off for the
next 24 hours and uh
my half vision lawyer bill richmond is
here he can confirm that our page on
facebook has been throttled for citing
cdc statistics
um so if you're trying to watch on
facebook uh really listen it's a 50 50
shot that this game gets
pulled or not uh so um
we just add please ask that to uh join
my club if you like someone if
someone walked into your work and said
hey there's going to be a pace we have
to make some pay cuts
like oh my gosh what's it going to be
well it could be five percent could be
45
i don't know well which is it that's
what i'm telling you all right see ya
that's what i'm saying that's what
happens when facebook and youtube
decide to throttle us uh but we're
working on it right there half asian
bill yes if i leave suddenly in the
middle
you'll know something is afoot and if i
leave suddenly in the middle
it's because i have a stomach bug don't
worry it's not the kovid
speaking of which do you know that on
this day in history last week uh
donald trump was diagnosed with covid
and now it's like it never happened oh
that's great let go fart in the wind
it's good he's back in the office ready
to go gerald a is here how are you
father treating him it's fantastic month
old right now oh
by the way we're also going to have the
uh uh costume contest yeah i'm not that
interested not so much
babies bore me it's unless they're my
own at least that's what i'm told and i
hope it's correct
otherwise it'll be tossed out a window
ouch oh
no fire station down into a bouncy hop
no you just do the michael jackson you
hang him out the window
right or you just do the michael jackson
story you ever heard of you just toss
the kid in the chimpanzee cage
oh wow don't irritate him oh bubbles
don't give him any jesus
juice bubbles no was it bubbles bubbles
that champ
that chimp was vicious as hell from oh
there's a documentary
near the chimp cage i gave him i gave
him jesus juice and xanax
of course he didn't michael oh no but
let's forgive it all because let's
forgive the fact that he was a glorified
pedophile with an ice cream truck
because he wrote smooth criminal
um laddersguider.com also slash whitmer
death toll where you can go and submit
your own foia request
um and print your whitmer death toll
posters there been a lot of those in
michigan right now and the supreme court
just struck down her unconstitutional
executive orders
right um costume contest after this of
course where we will uh
give the winner a lock of gerald's hair
drinking game rules let's bring them up
no we know we're not string game rules
anytime the vice president gets leading
unfair question has to defend trump's
character or the moderator teams up with
kamala and you hear this ding
you are to drink any time kamal harris
gets a softball question dodge is a
question
cackles evilly not sure if that's
spelled correctly or tries to be hip
namely listing uh rappers who've been
dead for
the last two and a half decades because
they're currently active
favorite rapper then you have to just
down your drink
yeah um let me this is this is what i
think tonight and i want to go to you
guys uh because the stream's about to
start really quickly
as far as what what pence needs he needs
a tie he needs a tie because
there's there's the identity politics of
white straight mail and then
there's white pence
and uh he is very good at staying on
point but kamala harris is a dirty
fighter she's very aggressive as a
prosecutor right but she doesn't do so
well on her heels and so i think what
pence needs to do is be disciplined
but tear a little bit of a page from
trump's book really more a page from
andrew breitbart's book and cut her off
at the pass if she starts bringing up
white supremacy he can just say
kamala do you believe i'm a white
supremacist why are you why are you
asking me that
if not stop wasting my time so he needs
to just sort of swat it down right pawd
away
and go right down the middle uh what do
you think half asian bill i think if if
kamala isn't ready to answer some of
those really tough questions that she
got during the
early debates she's going to have a big
problem i think she will have prepared a
lot especially right
remember the title gabriel the answer
was that joe biden's a racist and rapist
well she wasn't racy jim crow very clear
on that one so i think that's absolutely
right but i i
you know look mike mike pence has a lot
of appeal to certain groups uh
unfortunately albinos don't vote a lot
so
he's going to have to really give some
credibility here if he wants to
at least hit a top right now there's
some guy at home with his eyebrows
looked like they were burned off like
dartmouth
i think that pence is the respectable
side of the ticket he was brought on in
2016 to give trump a little bit more of
a kind of conservative face
um and i think that's his role here he's
got to be firm but he also has to be
respectable and i don't think that
matters so much because donald trump has
been the most conservative president in
modern history no no i know but i think
that's why he's brought in but i'm
saying i don't think he needs to play
that role of conservative enforcer
anymore
he needs to really just play the role of
enforcer against kamala
he's got to be careful he can't look
like another version of donald trump
he's got to look like somebody who's a
little bit more humble and a little bit
more
ready to pounce when the information is
incorrect but let you speak long enough
to hang yourself he needs to front load
it
heavy with facts otherwise come out and
then give her enough space so that
that way he can cut off at the pass and
then he can be mobile he can be fleet of
foot you know so that he can
he can move around her a little bit but
he's got to come out and front load it
be
be front heavy with the facts with the
information every answer he gives
two reasons that then allows him to be a
little more flexible so that he can show
that he can go off book because i think
it's a question mark with
with uh uh vice president pence as well
as
if he is going to have to fight off
kamala harris and a moderator it allows
him to get his info out and then it's
less consequential so
hopefully people there are taking notes
it's dana ashe
i hope he pisses her off by the way i
really do i hope he gets under her skin
but politely yeah but not responding
maybe the way that she wants when she
throws something out there but i hope
she gets riled because
when she does she is better i'm throwing
something out there notably a weighted
tin cup
yeah she's that's what she i expect her
to go
uh identity politics a little bit um you
know what she does need to do is she
does need to resolve some sort of
conflicting agendas right the sort of
radical progressive left agenda
and then there's the sort of
establishment agenda right right people
try to say she's a moderate where i
think she was actually rated as the most
liberal member of the senate right
not including favors to willie brown and
then um she has of course this really
crazy harsh agenda a long track record
as a prosecuting attorney and here's
something too giuliani made a good point
about this he said you know
as someone who's who's been a prosecutor
i've we've seen people like kamala
harris
they're what we call ladies they pad
their records she would arrest people
who are non-violent drug offenders to
pad her record and let
let the big fish get away then he
coughed so
um and i think that's true people need
to know that kamala harris has done
more to mass incarcerate non-violent
drug offenders people of color
and enslave them really to the state
beyond their sentence in some cases yeah
uh and let the big
the the big uh criminals who are causing
real damage go
yeah exactly and i i don't think she has
a leg to stand on with the record let
the lawyers speak
he don't know anything about law
just throw a fur at him i'd like to see
a pelt
wow hit him in the oh horse thing they
might be walking out then you missed
your chance half asian bill no no no i
got my
chance here it is kamala was attacked
repeatedly
for failing to actually articulate some
good
planks some position some something yeah
biden also failed to do that
so unless she has done something in the
last couple of months to learn
what her positions are and come out
there and articulate them clearly
she will fail to again inspire anyone to
come out and vote and that's what this
will turn
into is turnout yeah and i notice they
have plexiglass between them
because that stops a virus but i'm
hoping that someone gets checked into
the boards like a roller hockey that
would be fantastic
what do they have like desks why aren't
they standing well there's only
plexiglass to their sides
i know yeah so most of their talking is
going to be directly because microscopic
aerosol
particles can't you know they can't just
like look around first it's gonna hit
the moderator and bounce off again i
think the new york times even did an
article saying that that wasn't going to
do anything but hey thanks for trying
i i will say this about and again uh the
uh
hashtag is credited a basement you get
20 off if you join up there oh wait
wanna know how i got these scholarships
utah in salt lake city
welcome to the first and only vice
presidential rebate
of 2020. don't worry by the way
on presidential debates i'm susan page
of usa today
it is my honor to moderate this debate
democracy in kingsbury hall tonight we
have a small
and socially distant audience and we've
taken
extra precautions during this pandemic
mentally among other things
everyone in the audience is required to
wear face masks
on earlier in the audience talk about
low energy they look like kids who
wanted to go on the audience roller
coaster and instead got put
around yeah
at the end of the debate and now when i
introduce the candidates
please welcome california senator kamala
harris
and vice president mike pence
[Applause]
so right here we've got the contrast
we've got the gi joe look alike
and the generically ethnic on a gap ad
your guess is as good as mine first pos
candidate
for poc
oh but she wore the high heels just to
oh boy dig the knife
senator harris and vice president pence
thank you for being here a little bit
challenged we're meeting as president
trump and the first lady continue to
undergo treatment in washington
after testing positive for covert 19. we
send our thoughts and prayers to them
for their rapid and complete recovery
the two campaigns and the commission on
presidential debates have agreed to the
ground rules for tonight
i'm here to enforce them on behalf
of the millions of americans who are
watching jesus one note
no one in either campaign yeah or at the
prison guard
or anywhere else in advance what topics
i'll raise
two or what questions i'll ask this
90-minute debate will be divided into
nine
segments of about 10 minutes each i'll
begin a segment by posing a question
to each of you sometimes the same
question sometimes a different question
on the same topic you will then have two
minutes to answer
without interruption by me or the other
candidate
then we'll take six minutes or so to
discuss the issue
at that point although there will always
be more to say
we'll move on is she reading out the
rule card to risk we want
a debate that is
about the big issues facing our nation i
feel 40. let's begin with the honorable
keep writing down notes
across our country she's fixing her
rules already
senator harris the coronavirus is not
under control
over the past week johns hopkins reports
that
39 states have had more coveted cases
over the past seven days
than in the week before nine states have
set new records
even if a vaccine is released soon the
next administration will face
hard what would a choice administration
do in january and february
that a trump administration wouldn't do
would you impose
new lockdowns for businesses in schools
and hot spots
a federal mandate to wear mass lockdown
you have two minutes to respond
without interruption thank you susan
well the american people have witnessed
she's an inaudible answer by the way
of any presidential administration in
the history of our country
and here are the facts 210 000 dead
people in our country
in just the last several months over
seven million people who have contracted
this disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at front line workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers we are looking
at
over 30 million people shaking his head
who in the last several months had to
file for unemployment
and here's the thing on january 28th
the vice president and the president
were informed
about the nature of this pandemic they
were informed that it's lethal
in consequence that it is airborne
that it will affect young people
incorrect and that
incorrect airborne that's only let's
factor that that's only recently
that the idea of airborne is aerosol
particles
droplets let's be really clear about
that that is incorrect
better fact check that politifact meter
which everyone uses the pinocchios or
the meters
all of them better break better be a
broken wooden nose
and uh a meter that doesn't work the
president said it was a hoax
if you wear a mask you're on the other
side of his ledger if you don't
and in spite of all of that today they
still don't have a plan they still know
it don't happen
well joe biden does everything she's not
planning on answering any appropriations
to do around a national
strategy banned traveling in china
declared a national public health
emergency administration
they uh took a defense production they
got ppe they had to replenish the
stockpiles from
your candidate right who was vice
president at that point in time
i mean of course you guys have done
nothing and by the way joe biden was
nowhere
he was nowhere instead you let nancy
pelosi go out like your proxy telling
people to go eat dumplings in chinatown
thank you right to re-election based on
this thank you senator harris
oh she is coming out vice president more
than 210
000 americans have died of covet 19
since february why did you do this
the u.s death toll as a percentage is
higher than that of almost every other
wealthy nation
on earth for instance our death rate is
two and a half when did that matter
instead of canada next door
you had the administration's coronavirus
task force new york
why is the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
higher than that of almost every other
wealthy country
and you have two minutes to respond
without interruption susan thank you
and i want to thank the commission and
the university of utah for
hosting this event and uh senator harris
it's privileged to be on the stage with
you now go straight for the throat
and our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
i want you but i want the americans like
a
president donald trump has put the
health of america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
president donald trump did what no other
american president had ever done
and that was he suspended all travel
from true
people in the world you called joe biden
right now right kamala
senator also a rapist that decision
he said it was xenophobic and hysterical
hey he read our facts
i can tell you having led the white
house coronavirus task force that that
decision alone by president trump
bought us invaluable time to stand up
the greatest national mobilization
since world war ii and i believe it
saved hundreds of thousands of american
lives
because with that time we were able to
reinvent more than a hundred
million you would have to agree with
that because it was supposed to be we
were able to see to the delivery of
millions billions it was surprised so
our doctors and nurses had the resources
support they needed
and we began really before the month of
february was art to develop a vaccine
and to develop medicines and
therapeutics had been saving lives all
along the way
and under president trump's leadership
operation warp speed we believe we'll
have
literally tens of millions of doses of a
vaccine before the end of this which
will not take the reality is when you
look at the biden plan it reads an awful
lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing everything
when we get that i know we can go to
clip e1
when i look at that right now advancing
without your senses
developing a vaccine is the vice
president tobacco
it looks
around and [ __ ] gotta get up with that
ass smith pants what the hell senator
harris
would you like to read okay you don't
have to cultivate whatever the vice
president is claiming the administration
has done
clearly it hasn't worked when you're
looking at over two hundred and ten
thousand
dead bodies in our country american
lives
that have been lost families that are
grieving that loss
and that's also from jesus that's also
separated across
different flu seasons by the way it's
just a never-ending how
conditions he said because the president
wanted people to remain
calm well let's go no we should cause a
panic
attack a virus that of course if you are
under
50 has a 200 100 survival rate 99.99
8 survival rate if you're under the age
of 15
even if you're a fat son of a [ __ ]
when your kids were sent home from
school and you didn't know when they
could go back
okay thank you what is
let's give vice president pence a chance
to respond vice president you have one
of
them
there's another day gone by that i
haven't thought of every american family
that's lost a loved one
and i want all of you to know that
you'll always be an artist she was
thinking that bj's for mayors and in our
prayers
[Laughter]
but when you say what the american
people have done over these last eight
months hasn't
worked that's a great disservice yeah
the sacrifices the american people have
made
the reality if i make sense of let her
do this
the reality is dr fauci said everything
that he told
her a little bit overall
now president trump i will tell you has
boundless confidence in the american
people and he always spoke with
confidence that we'd get through this
together
but when you say it hasn't worked when
dr
fauci and dr burks and our medical
experts came to us in the second week of
march
they said if the president didn't take
the unprecedented step
of shutting down roughly half of the
american economy that we could lose 2.2
million americans and that's the reality
thank you they also said to us if we did
everything
but the american people i believe
deserve credit
for the sacrifices that they have made
putting the health of their family
and their neighbors first our doctors
our nurses our first thank you vice
president pence and i'm going to speak
up on behalf of what the american people
have done vice president pence you were
in the french smirking laughing
american 11 years ago
with your slave-owning ancestors but not
here
how can you expect americans to follow
the administration's
safety guidelines to protect themselves
from covid
when you at the white house have not
been doing so leading question drake
well the american people have
demonstrated
over the last eight months that when
given the facts
they're willing to put the health of
their families and their neighbors and
people they don't even know first
president trump and i have great
confidence in the american people and
and their ability to take that
information
and put it into practice in the height
of the epidemic
when we were losing a heartbreaking
number of 2
500 americans a day we surged resources
to new jersey and
new york and new orleans people
throughout the world
people made the sacrifice and they
rejected the outbreak of the sun belt
happened
they didn't have to do that in florida
as much as cuomo was killing them
waiting room
vacancy on the supreme court of the
united states uh has come upon us and
the president introduced judge amy coney
thank you thank you very much if i may
say that rose garden event
i've been a great deal of speculation
about it my wife karen and i were there
and honored to be there
many of the people who were at that
event susan actually were tested for
coronavirus
and it was an outdoor event which all of
our scientists regularly and routinely
advise
the difference here is president trump
and i trust the american people
to make choices in the best interest of
their health
joe biden and kamala harris consistently
talk about
mandates and not not just mandates with
the coronavirus but
a government takeover thank you thank
you
a little bit more
let's talk about respecting the american
people you respect the american people
when you tell them the truth
you respect the american people when you
have the courage to be a leader
speaking of those things that you may
not want people to hear but they need to
hear so they can oh by the way
come on what is the truth sweetheart
you want to do it with the electoral
college
standing in the food line because
of the ineptitude of an administration
that was unwilling to speak the truth to
the american people
so let's talk about caring about the
american people the american people have
had to sacrifice far
too much because of the incompetence of
this administration
it is asking too much of the people the
sacrifices are too much in blue states
where their economy is not recovering
and they have higher deaths in states
like texas and florida that have not had
lockdown so let's be really clear
it's not even close it's not even close
incompetence of the governors
uh senator harris i mean i'm sorry
that's fine i'm comma
no no you're senator harris to me
she's so likable
that most of the people who can be
vaccinated how dare you be back here we
go
but half of americans now say they
wouldn't take a vaccine if it was
released now
that's because you're an anti-vaccine
it's a trust administration slightly
darker
mccarthy should americans take it and
would you take it
if the public health professionals if dr
fauci if the doctors tell us that we
should first in line
[Laughter]
in recent days the president's diagnosis
of covert 19 has underscored the
importance
of the job really quickly show that
cliff i don't know how long it is
she wanted her saying she wouldn't take
the vaccination the role of the vice
president
let's just say there's a vaccine that is
approved and even distributed before the
election
would you get it well i think that's
going to be an issue for all of us
i will say that i would not
trust donald trump and it would have to
be
a credible source of information that
talks about the
um the efficacy and the and the
reliability
of whatever he's talking about i will
not take his word for it he wants us to
inject bleach no i will not take it off
because all right let's go back here
cut away from chin landing you think you
should you have two minutes without
interruption what was there well susan
uh thank you although i would like to go
back
i think we need to move on well thank
you but i would like to go back
because the reality
unheard is time in less than a year we
have
five companies in phase three clinical
trials
and we're right now producing tens of
millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine
public confidence in a vaccine if the
vaccine
emerges during the trump administration
i think is
is unconscionable and senator i just ask
you
stop playing politics with people's
lives the reality
is that we will right in the baby before
the end of this year
and it will have the capacity to save
countless american lives and
your continuous undermining of
confidence in a vaccine is just
it's just unacceptable and let me also
say
you know the reality is when you talk
about about failure in this
administration
we actually do know what failure looks
like in a pandemic
it was 2009. the swine arrived
thankfully it was ended up not being as
lethal
as the coronavirus but before the end of
the year
when joe biden was vice president of the
united states yes
not seven and a half million people
contracted the swine flu yes
60 million americans contracted the
swine flu
if the swine flu had been as lethal as
the coronavirus in 2009
when joe biden was vice president we
would have lost that was also your
people half-page
bill would say
last year that it was pure love you have
the worst gifts that they did quote
everything possible right new year toss
that iphone then
we learned from that they left the
strategic national stockpile
empty oh they left uh there it is
but we still learn from it and i i think
people know what to do
or reached an agreement with vice
president biden about safeguards or
procedures
when it comes to the issue of
presidential disability and if not
and if you win the election next month
susan he's still learning how to use
gotcha you should so we have two minutes
uh safeguard so let me tell you first of
all um the day i got
the call from from joe biden it was the
rapist actually you said it the racism
and racism on this ticket
was probably one of the most memorable
memorable days of my life um
i why did you try to dig it rape you
like i thought about my mother
didn't know racism came to the united
states at the age of 19
and gave birth to me at the age of 25 at
kaiser hospital in oakland california
um the thought that i'd be sitting here
right now um
she is eating up the time right now so
that there is no
accountability in her answers and i hate
to say but
there just like some women about the
value and the dignity of public servants
hits it right off the top and about the
importance of fighting for the dignity
of
that pink eye and i think joe asked me
to serve with him because
i think he got sucked you know i have a
career that included
justice system i was elected um the
first i know joe biden has been a woman
of color
[Laughter]
to the big banks that were taking
advantage of homes this is not the
answer
yeah what is this let me know by the way
we have your costume contest of course
we'll be taking your winners and we'll
be going exclusively this is not an
answer
this is remarkable kamala harris is
doing everything you know i i thought
that they were going gonna
kind of be dancing out there feeling
each other out a little bit you know
bobbing and weaving but instead
she's not bobbing and weaving pence's
attacks she's bobbing and weaving the
questions from the moderator and this
moderator is clearly trying to stack the
deck against pets
she went all the way back to her thought
that mike pence would come to the rescue
for the trump campaign nobody lifting up
the american people
and after the four years that we have
seen jumped out of the ring and run out
of the building
around common values and principles
like a centaur and just trampled
susan collins she said uh thank you very
much for your time she didn't say that's
not the answer
to any question let me hear the next
question president trump's doctors have
given
misleading answers or refuse to answer
basic questions about his health
and my question in turn is is this
information leading questions oh sorry i
won't do it anymore
no no gently
well susan thank you oh no and uh
and let me thank you on behalf of the
president
and the first lady how moved we've all
been she can't just go by the outpouring
of thanks
prayers and concern for the president
and i do believe it's emblematic of the
prayers and the concern that have
ushered forth for every american
impacted by the corona virus remind me
after this there was
the care of the president received and i
saw the doctors at walter reed hospital
white house doctors was exceptional and
the transparency that they practiced all
along the way will continue
the american people have a right to know
about the health and well-being
of their president and we'll continue to
do that
but i'm just extremely grateful and was
more than more than a little bit this
way updated by the broad
and bipartisan support senator i want to
thank you and joe biden for your
expressions
genuine concern and i also want to
congratulate you generously
on that phone call on the historic
nature of your nomination
i i never expected to be on this stage
four years ago so
i know the feeling but um the reality is
uh we've got an election before the
american people in the midst of this
challenging year
and the stakes have never been higher
but i think the choice has never been i
wanted to kind of
senator harris a chance to the question
that she asked questions
this is what's important to be a layup
and she didn't answer whereas his was
doctors were misleading about kovitz do
you hate trump so i thought i
said donald trump's doctors refused to
disclose status of his health and it was
a doctor saying he's doing well he
hasn't had a fever and someone said what
can we see his lung scans he said oh
listen the patient doctor
confidentiality privilege would extend
to the president so i can't give you his
lung scans
that's it refused he refused to answer
questions was he on oxygen well he's not
on oxygen right now
liars
and is in debt for 400 million dollars
and just so everyone is clear when when
we say
in debt it means you owe money to
somebody
and it'd be wrong
is he making those decisions on the best
interest of the american people of you
or self-interest so susan i'm glad you
asked about transparency
brent came because it has to be taken
care of she'd be the one blowing
ebenezer
over many many years and then she'd like
jump over to another novel like the page
master and go please
how can i have some more like that's not
even yes
but donald trump on the other hand has
been about covering up
everything thanks thank you senator
harris i want to give you a chance to
respond
vice president well look i i respect the
fact that joe biden spent 47 years in
public life
i respect your public servants i don't
respect that at all
the american people have a president
who's a businessman
it's a job creator who's paid tens of
millions of dollars in taxes payroll
taxes property taxes he's
created tens of thousands of american
jobs
and the president said those public
reports are not accurate
and the president's also released
literally stacks of financial
disclosures the american
people can review just as the law allows
but
the distinction here is that joe biden
47 years in
public service compared to president
donald trump who brought all of that
experience four years ago thank you
thank you very much turned this economy
around by cutting taxes
the amount of time that they're getting
now he needs to be shorter needs to be
more succinct
but they are not giving him the certain
amount of times they're getting hurt you
know that's
actually into our third topic which is
about the economy
this has been another aspect of come on
moderator if you're gonna bring up
donald trump
and bring up the lowest unemployment
american history the highest wage growth
lowest drug prices bring it up
bring it up susan bring it up susan
don't don't let me down susan 7.9
in september but the job growth had
solved and that was before the latest
round of layoffs and furloughs
in the airline industry at disney and
elsewhere hundreds of thousands of
discouraged workers have stopped looking
for work
nearly 11 million jobs that existed at
the beginning of the year
haven't been replaced those hardest hit
include latinos
blacks and women senator harris the
biden harris
campaign has proposed new programs to
boost the economy and you would have to
go through that lock them up
that's come on here's the program lock
them up and put them on the side of the
freeway
some economists warn that could curb
entrepreneurial ventures
that fuel growth and create jobs would
you rate
it because she heard entrepreneurial
recovery at risk
and you have two minutes to answer i'm a
child you are
it's okay um we love you on the issue of
the economy i
think there couldn't be a more
fundamental difference between donald
trump
and joe biden joe biden believes you
measured the health
and the strength of america's economy
based on the health
and the strength of the american worker
and the american family oh yeah what was
wage growth
based on how rich people are doing which
is why
unemployment is down to 118.48.2 barack
obama had
over nine percent leading to
on day one joe biden will repeal that
tax bill
she means on day 48 years
and 1. yeah that's true you do have to
count because we're supposed to believe
he's going to run it now they all count
i don't think it ever happens it's a
hard thing to do
joe biden will do that he'll invest in
infrastructure it's about upgrading our
roads and bridges but also
investing in clean energy and renewable
energy again
invest that money in what we need to do
around innovation
there was a time when our country
believed in science
and invested in research and development
so that
what is your view on nuclear harris the
most renewable resource that we possibly
have you can compare germany
and france germany has power surpluses
and brownouts when they tried to go to
entirely
renewable energy and ignore nuclear
whereas france actually has
fewer carbon emissions than the
countries that signed onto this protocol
to lower their carbon emissions through
soil because guess what
it takes a lot of energy to mine those
materials to put those up and then
they're incredibly energy inefficient so
you have to rely on whatever else you
have which is usually coal
and natural gas as opposed to nuclear
energy you do not agree with the science
do you know how many accidents have
taken place with nuclear
three ever three major experts three
mile island fukushima
and uh and chernobyl and most of the
deaths had to do with the evacuation
procedures and not actually from nuclear
radiation poisoning
not saying it's entirely safe but what
happened to the science
senator bj let's go uninterrupted two
and a half minutes
when president trump and i took office
how long was that foreign depression
when joe biden was vice president that
tried to tax and spend and regulate
and bail our way back to a growing
economy failed president trump cut taxes
across the board despite what uh senator
harris says
the average american family of four had
two thousand dollars in savings in taxes
and true with the rising wages that
occurred
most predominantly for blue-collar
hard-working americans
the average household income for a
family of four increased by four
thousand dollars following president
trump's tax cuts
but america you just heard senator
harris tell you on day one
joe biden's going to raise your taxes
yep it's really remarkable
i mean right after a time where we're
going through a pandemic that lost 22
million jobs at the height
she doesn't know what to do
yeah because we had a president who cut
taxes rolled back regulation
unleashed american energy fought for
free and fair trade
and secured four trillion dollars
mike pence after this debate the best
thing that could happen for mike pence
is you fact check the worst thing that
could happen with kamala harris
is you hit rewind and try to find
anything worth factoring joe biden wants
to go back to the economic surrender to
china that when we took office
half of our international trade deficit
was with china alone
and joe biden wants to repeal all of the
tariffs that president trump put into
effect to fight for american jobs and
american workers
joe biden says democracy's on the ballot
make no mistake about it susan
the american economy the american
comeback is on
the ballot with four more years of
growth thank you an opportunity
four more years of president donald
trump two and a half minutes 20 21 thank
you very much the biggest economic year
thank you vice president pence senator
harris well i mean i that we saw enough
of it in last week's debate but i think
this is supposed to be a debate based on
fact and truth
and the truth and the fact is bill biden
has been very clear is it any opposition
will not raise taxes on anybody who
makes less than four hundred thousand
just so conveniently average for the
presidential salary
i was like only raise taxes what do
twice in the debate last week that he's
going to repeal the trump tax cuts right
which would raise taxes
of course trump raised taxes on all
thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year that is absolutely
not true
in their pocket at the end have a
conversation okay please
oh my god
is the one who during the the great
recession was responsible
for making it worse for the recovery act
that brought america back and now the
trump
pence administration wants to take
credit
when they ran when they rode the court
coattails of joe biden's success
really for the economy that they had at
the beginning
while we're fact checking but kamala
harris just claimed
that the economy that you are seeing
obviously before coveted in 2020 2019
was a rip-roaring success
because of joe biden when the guy who
was actually
running the game while joe biden was
president unemployment was still pretty
much
oh i think the average is about twice
what it was with donald trump 3.5
i don't know if we've ever seen 3.5
unemployment in our lifetime let alone
with the labor force participation rate
wow
she just tried to say the economy was
doing well under trump
because of joe biden by the way just
tried to blame the economy uh with covet
due to democratic governor policies on
donald trump so which is it sweetheart
be clear north south north south north
south you'll lose protections
if you have pre-existing conditions and
identity this is very important susan
yes and it's about we need to give
we need to get vice president i just
like he interrupted me and i'd like to
just
mommy the straight white male
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
they're coming for you
sweetheart that must be my pheromones
are we're throwing you into a tizzy
oh president trump and i have a plan
listen
to improve health care i understand your
barren home has your temperamental
button
american i understand it's only that
senator harris you're
you're entitled to your own opinion but
you're not entitled to your own facts
you yourself multiple occasions when you
were running
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the eye
and pointed and said i guarantee i
guarantee
that we will abolish fossil fuels they
have a 2 trillion
version of the green new deal susan that
your newspaper usa today said
really wasn't that very different from
the original green new deal oh by the
way
more taxes more regulations we now move
on planning tracking
abolishing fossil fuel crushing american
energy
and economics by the way some of the
people that understand is a prescription
having americans in charge of their own
fossil fuels
is more eco-friendly than saudi arabia
oh yeah oh god
well then we don't beat our women hey
it's diverse continue
i just don't know if i can i just don't
know if i can hit right is that a guy or
a that's once again
he don't hate him i don't know but he's
getting out you don't ask you don't ask
climate change is it they and vice
president pence i'd like to pose the
first question
to you this year we've seen
record-setting hurricanes in the south
another one hurricane delta is now
threatening the gulf it's trump's
we have seen record-setting wildfires
out there
as the scientific community has
concluded that man-made climate change
has made wildfires bigger hotter they
haven't been more deadly
they haven't made their own included
while you're cherry-picking facts how
about you bring up the fact that we have
record high great lakes and record crop
yields in the midwest and by the way
the most temperate climates that we have
seen in places like the midwest in texas
positively balmy and cool look i'm
running both a dehumidifier
and a humidifier at the same time to
give it a perfect like like a walking
humidor
in the world and just a little while ago
the president signed the outdoors act as
the largest investment in our public
lands and public parks
in a hundred years well i was like
that's not in my president trump has
made a commitment to conservation
now with regard to climate change it's
not a laugh the climate is
changing oh by the way drink because i
was i'm shooting questions
what's the cause and what do we do about
it president trump has made it clear
that we're going to continue to listen
to the science
now joe biden and kamala harris would
put us back in the
paris climate accord they'd impose the
green new deal yeah
which would crush no no you won't do it
or you will do it
because that's a five-page bill that
takes over everything yeah
president trump and i will she said she
would abolish the filibuster to make
sure it passed
okay well until they need it it's been
happening precisely because we have a
strong
free market economy you know what's
remarkable is
the united states has reduced co2
more than the countries that are still
in the paris climate accord but we've
done it through
truth
which senator the american people can go
look at the record i
i know joe biden says otherwise now as
you do
but the both of you repeatedly committed
to abolishing fossil fuels
a fracking and so by creating the kind
of american
innovation of course it's not true of
course
they said they were going to be
wildfires the reason they have to pivot
from that is not just because it's
creative jobs but because people now
understand that fracking is actually
better for the environment
than having to bring oil over on tankers
across volatile waters people are
understanding that now more and more
at first it was oh chemicals in the
ground and i saw that guy who has a
young turk show who lit a faucet on fire
then people said i made a video of that
happening in the 50s they were like all
skunked again
years ago thank you but many of the
climate alarms
use hurricanes and wildfires to try and
save those
goods of a green new deal it really has
said in last week's debate that he does
not support the green new deal
but if you look at the biden harris
campaign website it describes the
greener deal
as a crucial framework right what
exactly
would be the stance of a biden-harris
administration
towards answer this everyone shut up i
want to hear her answer this directly
so first of all i will repeat and the
american people know
that joe biden will not ban fracking
that is a fact
he said he will answer the question on
green new deal sweetheart i will
repeat that joe biden has been very
clear
that he's going to be jobs which is why
he will not
increase taxes for anyone who makes less
than four hundred thousand dollars a
year
joe biden's economic plan moody's
which is a reputable wall street firm
has said we'll create
seven million more jobs than donald
trump's
and part of those jobs that will be
created by joe biden
are going to be about clean energy and
renewable energy
green new deals because you see answer
the question don't understand you just
lie
about fracking where's the video we can
pull up that video including my home
state of california
she asked about the green new deal
specifically they never answered will
you pack reports
let me tell you joe biden has just seen
and talked with
the pharmacist green new deal let me
tell you joe biden will not raise taxes
on anyone making more than the president
and so joe believes again in science
i'll tell you something susan i served
when i first got to the senate
on the committee that's responsible for
the environment do you know this
administration
took the word science off the website
and then took the phrase climate change
off the website
this we have seen every new deal we'll
give you one more
chance west indian trading company but
they changed the website
we're gonna deal with it but we're also
how about you change your website
where it says
on what is an existential threat to us
as human beings
joe is about saying we're going to
invest that in renewable energy
it's going to be about the creation of
millions of jobs three seconds three new
deals yes no go
nut um zero emissions do the phoebe
carbon neutral vitamin k
we will also re-enter the climate
agreement with pride
senator harris just said that climate
change is an existential threat
vice president pence do you believe that
climate change poses an existential
threat
as i said susan the climate is changing
we'll follow the science
but once again uh senator harris um
is denying the fact that he's going to
raise taxes this is something else
everyone needs to know
because i can speak a little bit by the
way have a watch along folks because we
do have to
commentate at least more than average
otherwise they might ban us she asks a
very specific question right there to
kamala harris
kamala harris did not answer she let her
off the hook green new deal it's on your
website didn't answer it
then she asks there you go right in the
website green new deal is a crucial
framework also they said they were going
to ban fracking then she asks
vice president mike pence she asks him a
very specific she asked him a very broad
question
but requires a specific answer climate
change she said as an existential threat
do you believe that that's the case and
he'll say well listen we'll follow the
science which is an entirely appropriate
answer that's not an appropriate answer
for
your website says green new deal right
do you believe that's an existential
threat well i think that'll be
determined by the science because
science by the way is not the science
science is something that develops that
changes a lockdown was appropriate
at the beginning of this pandemic
knowing science
now and the cdc revising their own
survival rates to about a hundred
percent for people in the age of 50
that's what science is
science develops science progresses
science is a catalyst for things moving
forward
but she says what do you do you think
it's an existential threat and then
she'll call him on it for not answering
specifically
specific question she doesn't answer at
all a broad question
he answers with an appropriate broad
answer and then he gets called to the
man
i don't
i do i like i like what he's doing yeah
he's doing good here's to our
environment and follow the science thank
you
thank you so on the issue of jobs
senator let's talk about that
hand you the vice president earlier
what he thinks is an accomplishment um
the the president's
trade war with china you lost that trade
war no you lost no
you didn't no what ended up happening is
because of the so-called trade
you came back america on the horse
because of it we are in a manufacturing
recession
because of it no and when we look at
where this administration we're putting
in manufacturing under the obama
administration
and we've now managed to mitigate those
losses
that's one of those things where she
doesn't want you to fact check her right
president she doesn't
let's just use your common sense here
let's just use
right your little rationalization
portion of your noggin okay
you know do you think that nafta or the
trans-pacific partnership
actually helped create american jobs
right now and you're wondering
just you just do you really cause they
went all in on that people who are
trying to figure out all right let's
start they're gonna pay rent by the end
of the month almost half of american
renters
are worried about whether they're gonna
be able to pay rent oh man
basically stealing it from the from the
owners of the property has nothing to do
with creating jobs this is the
fundamental difference
they don't know how to create jobs when
they say hey how are you going to create
jobs what do you how do you view the
economy
well he uh you know he just he wanted
more americans to to
to have jobs but we need to take from
the property owners and give it to the
to the people who are renting i recently
has been a cheerleader for communist
china through
over the last several decades yeah baby
and that's my
joe biden was vice president we lost 200
000 manufacturing jobs
and president obama said they were never
coming back
to bring them back in our first three
years after we cut taxes
regulations just real quick the seven
million jobs she referenced earlier
even the washington post admitted all of
that would be funded
through having a democratic controlled
senate and white house that would pass
deficit spending so essentially yes we
will tax more
right take that money create jobs and go
look we created gyms right
15 seconds thank you thank you that's
that's a good harry reid joe biden
is responsible for saving america's auto
industry and you voted against it
so let's get the record straight no he's
not he's not responding i'd like to talk
about the american
taxpayers are responsible for bail and
the chevy volt
sucks still sucks sucked then sucks now
foreign relationship by the way you want
to know how crony the democratic party
is but
ford did not want to take the bailout
and they were forced to they said no no
you're going to do this because we can't
make this work with the uaw right in
these agreements if you don't go in
uh it would be a shame if i broke some
[ __ ] i shouldn't have hit the thing that
was chained down it'd be a shame if i
broke
broke [ __ ] ford huh take the bail out
competitors
those are some nice cars you got there'd
be shame if they caught
everybody knows that nafta cost
literally thousands of american
factories to close
this we saw automotive jobs go south
speaking from
far class in michigan in the united
states
canada agreements who have really parted
ways i'll i'll go back to that people
deserves a new
strategy senator kamala harris was one
of only 10 members of the senate to vote
against the usmca
it was a huge win for american auto
workers it was a huge win for american
farmers especially derry in the upper
midwest
but senator you recently didn't go far
enough from california she's dairy
you put your your radical environmental
agenda
ahead of american auto workers and ahead
of american
jobs and the american people deserved
newsweek magazine said that that kamala
harris was the most
liberal member of the united states look
at our policies if you look at the
equitable trade agreements we created
more american jobs we encourage
businesses
to return this manufacturing to the
united states right he's talking about
giving a fishing pole and lures and bait
and bobbers and and she's just like
taking the president
he's not happy about it he's like i got
a fishing pole
you take the fish china and the world
health organization you know what i'm
not going to cheat what am i going to
teach you
what am i retired there are mayors out
there haven't had a nob polished in a
month and a half you tend to fish
i got a job to do president trump in
dealing with china from the outset of
this administration standing up to china
that had been taking advantage of
america for decades
in the wake of joe biden's chairman what
happened there's so little
president trump made that decision
before the end of
the president
thank you senator harris let me ask you
the same
question that i asked the vice president
come on how would you describe
our fundamental relationship for those
who are watching online i can't see
stephen he's cleaning up the mess he
made when he was very very angry
about his stupidity susan the
trump administration's perspective
and approach to china has resulted in
the loss of american
lives oh really america wait what jobs
how
and america's standing excuse me how
there's a weirdo
she just says period
she thought that was a mic job was
achieved by president obama and vice
president biden
for example they created within the
white house
an office that basically was responsible
for monitoring pandemics
they got away they they got rid of it no
they didn't get rid of it
was they didn't get rid of the
dispatched to china to monitor
what is now predictable and what might
happen they pulled them so exist
right
[Laughter]
and the actual unsavory financial ties
of biden and china
you got mad when he called up the
chinese virus over 300
manufacturing jobs and a manufacturing
recession
and the american consumer paying
thousands of dollars more for goods
because of that fail did we war that
they called it i don't know and let's
talk about
standing pew the reputable research firm
pew is what i say to your business i've
done an analysis
that shows again with leaders of
chinese communist party then they do
donald trump
of the united states the
commander-in-chief of the united states
this is where we are today because of a
failure of leadership by this
administration
senator harris oh she's sponsoring me
an answer right now rant that was like
mr bean in the movie
illusions near the end of this now
[Laughter]
as the vice president mentioned we've
seen our traditional
of the role of american leadership in
2020
so you know joe is i love talking to joe
about
a lot of these issues and you know
did fdr have some vp he was like ignore
the wheelchair he's a racist see
is that he has betrayed our friends
and it it and and and and and
embraced dictators around the world who
let's take for example
russia how has he embraced russia really
let's
obama and russia versus donald trump and
russia not your fake steel dossier
made up entirely scandal let's let's be
clear about that
what's the obama policy on russia versus
donald trump
what are the sanctions how have we
behaved with them internationally you
tell me sweetheart
what's here but donald trump the
commander-in-chief of the united states
of america
prefers to take the word of vladimir
putin over the word of the american
intelligence community
you look at our friends at nato can we
get a reference here he's walked away
what is she talking about in the bill
every single time you go out for dinner
they're not your friends
that's everyone else at nato who got
people to finally start paying their
their whopping two percent at nato
arsenal
we were in that deal guys that only
happened if you have some strength as a
leader
i think you'd be hard-pressed to find
anyone who would say that joe biden or
barack obama
were stronger leaders than donald trump
you may say hey he's a dick for going in
and asking everyone else in nato to
honor their fair share of the agreement
you may not like it but he actually got
it done
barack obama didn't biden had 48 years
he could have spoken in someone's ear
instead he was busily grabbing he was
busy grabbing tips our word but donald
trump
doesn't understand that because he
doesn't understand
what it means to be honest thank you
thank you very much
really miss no answer the green new deal
which you just put up on your website
trump kept his word when we moved the
american embassy to jerusalem
the capital of the state of israel bound
when joe biden was vice president they
promised to do that and they never did
oh we're still strong with our allies
but we've been demanding
nato is now contributing more to our
common defense than
ever before thanks to president trump
and we've stood strong against those who
would do us harm
you know when president trump came into
office isis had
captured an area of the middle east the
size of pennsylvania
but president trump unleashed the
american military
and our armed forces destroyed the isis
caliphate
and took down their leader obama america
yeah that's right responsible exactly
for the death of thousands um
but notably america's hearts today are
with the family of kayla mueller
your parents which are here with us
tonight in salt lake city
today two of the isis killers
responsible for kayla mueller's murder
were brought to justice in the united
states
jihadi john was killed on the
battlefield along with the other beetle
the reality is that joe biden was vice
president we had an opportunity a little
weird
to save kayla miller breaks my heart to
reflect on it but the military came into
the ocean
presented a plan they said they knew
where caleb was
baghdadi had held her for 18 months
abused her mercilessly before they
killed her but okay by
and when armed forces finally went in it
was clear she'd been moved two days
earlier
and her family says with a heart that
broke the heart of every american that
if president donald trump had been
president they believe kayla would be
alive today
thank you very much we destroyed the
isis caliphate
uh and you talk about re-entering the
iran nuclear deal i mean the last
administration transferred 1.8 billion
dollars
for the leading state sponsor thank you
very much for terrorism
president donald trump got us out of the
debate thank you vice president really
you let her know i'm not answering the
green new deal question but he's
actually talking about a life saver from
islamic terrorist bricks
and you
allies are safer and the american people
know president donald trump will never
thank you vice president take action i
would like to give senator harris a
chance to respond but not at such great
length because i think
why am i here if i can't sue that guy
i'm so sorry
um what happened to her you'll get there
man i believe in you
and it should have never happened yeah
it should and i know joe feels the same
way
and i know that president obama i
thought we checked him out but you know
um but you mentioned so money let's
let's start there
yeah yeah we killed that so after the
strike on solomon you pay him we kill
him
obama did that strike on our troops
she's going to claim killing bin laden
which right and
well she didn't do it no it's basically
it was a serious
brain injury and do you know what donald
trump can play i think she's going to
say black america did it
and this is about a pattern of donald
trump's where he has referred
to our men who are serving in our
military as
suckers and losers
go [ __ ] yourself just hop off a mayor's
willy for five minutes if you find the
time sweetheart
that's been rebuffed rebuked
including john bolton who really wants
it to be true and by the way
there are email records the reason
donald trump didn't visit those troops
in that scenario was in fact because of
weather
there are records this is what's
happening again he wants you to fact
check him on everything whether
listen this should i will be surprised
if a poll shows anyone coming out the
victor outside of mike pence with a
landslide here tonight and i was
objective i said that donald trump did
not perform as needed to at the last
debate right
right in this scenario this is
remarkable
when you look at the specifics and the
actual facts and data that mike pence
has been
reciting and then the kind of cheap
attacks like that that you see from her
the debunked attacks that only cnn and
msnbc are still carrying
and donald trump had talked at least six
times to vlog after the vendor character
so everyone drink and never brought the
drinking
rules again for people
would hold russia to account for any
threat
how to our nation's our troops
who are threatened against
15 seconds because we're trying to
men and women of our armed forces are
absurd i'm sorry my son is a captain in
the united states marine corps
my son-in-law is exploring the united
states navy
i can assure all of you with sons and
daughters serving in our military
president donald trump not only respects
but reveres
all of those who serve in our armed
forces and any suggestion otherwise
it's ridiculous thank you vice president
american people american people i didn't
know
vice president i did not excuse you i
did not create the rules for tonight
joe biden agreed to the rules for
tonight's debate
with the commission on president trump
you agree to the rules with the
nominee for supreme court and hearing
and you accuse him of gang rape
you also agree to rules to try and focus
on policy you've let her skirt every
single answer
and then she came out and said that he
called the troops losers and suckers
which by the way has been entirely
debunked
there's there's there is no verification
on that at all other than anonymous
sources saying that they heard donald
trump say mean words
that's the platform of the democratic
party you want the people running
america
it's gonna be like a game of telephone
with retards yeah cement
the court's conservative majority and
make it likely open to
abortion restrictions even to
overturning the land
would then be up to the states vice
president pence
you're the former governor of
indianapolis roe v wade is overturned
what would you want indiana to do would
you want by the way
i'm gonna need another cerveza uh please
uh
you can make it a mode yet because well
thank you for the question
uh i'll use a little bit of my time to
run out onto that very important issue
before thank you
the american people deserve to know
carson salamani the iranian general was
responsible for the death of
hundreds of american service members
when the opportunity came we saw him
headed to bed attracted to kill more
americans president trump
they all need to look at the casting
call
and kamala harris actually criticized
the decision to take out solomon
uh salamani it's really inexplicable
but with regard to joe biden it's it's
explainable
because history records that joe biden
actually opposed the raid against osama
bin laden
it's absolutely essential that we have a
commander-in-chief
who will not hesitate to act to protect
the americans i don't know whether
that's
i live in this world and i did not know
that joseph biden but the opposing race
because that clears the ledger any
military wins yeah
she's a brilliant woman and uh she will
bring a lifetime of experience and
a sizable american family to the supreme
court of the united states
and our hope is
with treatment from you and others but
we hope she gets a fair
thank you solomania and we particularly
hope that we don't see
the kind of attacks on her continue to
burn so christian fearful
will impose a raid on him the democrat
chairman of the judiciary committee
before
when when judge barrett was being
confirmed for the court of appeals
expressed concern that the
dogma of her faith lived loudly in her
unless there are catholics molesting
you're the senator from and former
attorney general of california so let me
ask you a parallel question to the one i
posed to the vice president we do have
the headline on the
if roe v wade what would you want
no restrictions look at that access to
abortion oh this is absolutely true
make sure we know this one no
restrictions on access to abortion all
the way up until and including birth
that is her policy people of faith
and it's insulting to suggest that we
would
knock anyone for their faith and in fact
joe quotes
if elected will be only the second we
find i think i have some questions
practicing catholic uh as president of
the united states
um on the issue now we're getting a
little more practicing
yeah joe and i are very good yeah those
are the majority of the american people
i think that smiles 27. she lies she
does a little
decision about who will be the next
president of the united states
and you know before when this
conversation has come up you know it's
been about election year or election
time we're literally in an election
over four million people have voted
society
people are in the process of voting
right
now
zombie take the shot quick quick
question uh what is the catholic
church's stance
on abortion go when over 210
000 people have died and seven million
so yeah she co-sponsored the women's
health protection
which would eliminate or requirements on
abortion
after fetal viability donald trump is in
court right now if the treating
healthcare provider decides that the
continuation of a pregnancy could pose a
risk not death
a risk for example pose a risk like i
want to have a kid anymore yeah well
they can think it could pose mental risk
as well like
she just can't handle her and by the way
she's also a fascist because she would
overturn over 400 limitations on
abortions that have been imposed by
states which is what was on their right
let's go back to her not answering the
question you can't stay on your parents
coverage anymore and here's something
about health care
the contrast couldn't be more clear
they're trying to get better
basement losers voting for democrats
they'd have no base
for some 20 there's some 26 year old
right now yeah just speaking my language
i want to be in my parents health blew
up you know
you mentioned uh earlier vice president
pence that the president was committed
to maintaining protections for people
with pre-existing conditions
um and but you do have this court case
that you are supporting your
administration supporting
that would strike down the affordable
care act yes the president says damn
straight president trump says
he's already signed up
specifically how would your
administration protect
americans with pre-existing conditions
have access to affordable insurance
if the affordable care act is structural
there's protecting pre-existing
conditions
and then guaranteeing affordable
insurance how do you have everyone get
on insurance
after they develop diabetes from a diet
of fried
snickers and gym socks and then they say
well i'd like to purchase insurance now
how do you keep costs low right you can
either have an exemption for
pre-existing conditions
but it will have to be expensive unless
all americans want to see a
multi-hundred percent increase
in premiums and deductibles as we have
seen under obamacare right let's be
really clear you can't have all the
above
to the moment of birth the gym stocks
are free they want to increase funding
to planned parenthood
of america yeah now for our part i i
would never presume how judge amy coney
barrett
would rule on the supreme court of the
united states yeah
um you wouldn't want to manage your
complaints strong for the right to life
when you speak about the supreme court
though i think the american people
really deserve an answer senator harris
oh yes
there we go are you and joe biden going
to pack the court
shark laser beam i mean there have been
29 vacancies
on the supreme court during presidential
election years from george washington to
barack obama
presidents have nominated in all 29
cases
but your party is actually openly
advocating
adding seats to the supreme court which
has had nine seats for 150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules
you're going to change you refuse to
answer the question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
with the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
somehow pack the supreme court to get
your way
i'm so glad we went through a little
history lesson let's do that a little
more
and not answer the questions i'd like
you to answer the questions
of the president i i assume if you also
mr vice president is blind
hospital in oakland abraham lincoln's
every time she does not answer any
questions i do not advocate people dying
please do not follow that it came open
on the united states supreme court
abraham lincoln's party was in charge
not only of the white house but the
senate
who was not in session but honest aid
said it's not the right thing to do
because nobody's american town
deserved to be making a civil war about
who will be the next president of the
united states and you have to go back to
1964 to find out
hey by the way and so joe and i are very
clear the americans you're going to pack
the cards
i don't you're going to pack the cards
now are you going to pack the courts
i'm going to do this
on this most important body for a
lifetime
are you gonna pack the car thank you
senator are you gonna do it
do your [ __ ] job are you gonna pack
the carts are you gonna buy the carts
mike pence had to ask the question that
every american wants to know
she shocked it and you didn't follow joe
biden he's asking
him he's trying to answer you the
american people deserve a straight
answer and you didn't have you haven't
figured it out
they are going to pack the supreme court
if they somehow win this
election i got to tell you people across
this country if you cherish ourselves
yeah why do you want to run trust in
american institutions you need to reject
miss anderson come november the 3rd
re-elect
president donald trump and we'll stand
by that separation powers in a nine-seat
supreme court yeah let's talk about
packing the court then
let's talk about that please let's talk
about it answer it too
so don't say the man's planning
administration
has been because i sit on the senate
judiciary committee susan as you
mentioned
and i've witnessed the appointments for
lifetime appointments to
the federal courts district courts
courts of appeal
people who are purely ideological people
who have
been reviewed by candidates people i
don't professional organizations and
found to have been
not competent are substandard
and do you know getting my drinking hand
ready
who president trump appointed to the
court of appeals for a lifetime of what
are you going to pack the courts not one
is black
what is that what they've been doing you
want to talk about packing okay
let's have that discussion well well
then thank you thank you
let's go on and talk about wow let's
talk about it without you
i'm sorry but do your [ __ ] job
people say this is why moderate debates
when they're abroad on stage
i get your little sisterhood
taylor's boyfriend said he didn't hear
them do that he used a gun registered
to fire a shot which yeah i think it's a
little bigger
i think you've got 20 rounds yeah yeah
yeah i got to cut it
you got to cut it just cut it
and her family deserves justice she was
a beautiful young woman
she had as her life goal to become a
nurse and she wanted to become an emt
to first learn what's going on out on
the street
she
that's what the boyfriend said but then
he went back and then he said it again
apparently that's more relevant than a
direct question
hey will you pack the course kamala
harris hey why is the green new deal on
your website
it must be nice to be a democrat woman
and have to answer for
nothing whereas when you're amy coney
barrett you have to answer new york
times
op-eds as to whether your adoption of
underprivileged
black children is modern-day slave
ownership
must be nice to be kamala harrison just
never call to account for anything you
say
or do shoulder to shoulder arm and arm
during covet
fighting but it was okay for us to
finally achieve that ideal of equal
justice
under law uh really and i was what does
science say about
covet and molotov
for the values that we hold dear
including the fight to achieve our
ideals
and that's why joe biden and i have said
on this subject
look and i'm a former career prosecutor
i know what i'm talking about
back home do you want to talk about that
i know what i'm doing we need reform
you want to talk about the career
leasing in america and our criminal
justice system which is why
joe and i will immediately ban
chokeholds and carotid holes
george floyd would be alive today if we
did that um
no matter of fact it would have been
safer if they could have used a
chokehold because actually could have
gone unconscious
as opposed to having a knee in his
cervical spine
dummy i'm fine yeah
marijuana baby we can bring that right
choke out audio weighed
on air i've been choked unconscious at
least eight times anyone who's done
brazilian jiu jitsu has
i accidentally did it overdosed
people in america thank you let's spend
guns for cops let's ban chokeholds let's
ban tasers
no stickers it doesn't yeah no
was justice i'm a whistle you have two
minutes uninterrupted
oh boy leading question was justice done
holy [ __ ] wow
yeah the loss of innocent any innocent
american life
and the family of brianna taylor has our
sympathies
but i i trust our justice system [ __ ]
makes sense
chris wallace look like yeah john
stossel
is worse as a former prosecutor blame
the grant you would assume
in this case grand jury looking at all
the evidence got it wrong yeah but
you're entitled to your opinion a grand
jury of your peers he said
no charges and with regard to george
floyd there's no excuse for what
happened to george floyd
quite a few justice will be served but
there's also no excuse for the rioting
and looting
yeah why don't we ask her about her is
it the minnesota foreign fund which by
the way is
set free she was tweeting out support
for it let me find this i
these crimes uh incorrect
she yeah the minnesota freedom fund they
she supported tweeted out paid a hundred
thousand dollars to free darnica floyd
who stabbed a friend to death paid 350
000 free christopher boswell
twice convicted not charged i hope
you'll appreciate that half-assing bill
twice convicted rapist who's currently
charged with kidnapping assault sexual
assault
then seventy-nine thousand of three
jaleel stallings can i get a one
who shot a member uh members of a swat
team during the riots in may give a
shout out to all of them sweetheart
since you raised their money money well
spent on their terms
is is a great insult
for the millionaires enforcement and i
want everyone
are you sure about the fact in the
courts brought together and democrats
senators fly away
you got up and walked out of the room
and then you filibustered senator
a tim scott's bill on the senate floor
that would have provided new
accountability new repeat resources
but we don't have to choose between
supporting law enforcement
improving public safety and supporting
our african-american
nation under president trump's
leadership thank you very much always
stand with law enforcement and we'll do
what we do thank you
i'm surprised it hasn't been removed
tonight but get rid of that i know it's
a little weird
i gotta i gotta ask vice president on
what it means
to enforce the laws of our country i am
the only one on this stage
who was personally prosecuted arrested
bill i was going to say in terms of the
question i want to hear
what was the best answer you heard or
question you heard
from biden and the reason being is that
there was a real great question in there
there's true and it was about packing
the courts to get in here
from pence from pets i want to have that
on a loop like a morphine drinking about
that
i'm not sure that it didn't leave her
mouth left the president of the united
states took a debate but she grabbed the
warden's crotch in the green mile
like in constantine white supremacists
not true
and not true boy it wasn't like he
didn't have a chance
how about you condemn the two billion
dollar damage of the 14
000 arrest a thousand officer casualties
30 people dead
over 500 riots across the country
sweetheart
and by the way you freed criminals who
were convicted rapists
you tweeted out support for a fund how
about you answer that also
you're gonna pack the courts how the
fly's gone thank god
rapists and criminals rapists
did that you put non-violent drug
offenders behind bars
and then you supported the minnesota
freedom fund that led convicted rapists
out the need for racial justice where a
young woman was killed
and on the other side there were
neo-nazis carrying tiki torches
shouting racial epithets
anti-semitic slurs
there were fine people on both sides
really oh my god okay listen i have not
said this before this is a very clear
line now between good and evil yes
these are flat out lies green new deal
it's on your website do you support it
not answering
packing the course do you support it not
answering uh donald trump called troops
suckers and losers completely verifiably
debunked
she's set free twice convicted rapists
and now she says something that we all
know is a lie just watch that video you
can go watch
my type in stephen kreider donald trump
white supremacist you can watch the
entire video in context
where he said several times at that
meeting i'm not talking about white
supremacists
and neo-nazis who should be condemned
totally absolutely
she is lying she doesn't she doesn't
care
that she's lying and she doesn't plan on
you knowing because the moderator isn't
doing her job and she knows that the
rest of the media
will act will follow suit of that
moderator tomorrow morning
this should get 500 pinocchios
which she would proceed to rub back and
forth vigorously if it's a mayoral
position
go ahead this is a president who who
respects and cherishes all of the
american people
but you talk about having personally
promised i'm glad
i really need to make this point when
you were when you were d.a
in san francisco when you left office
african-americans were 19 times more
likely to be prosecuted for minor drug
offenses
he's right there in the fight right now
he's right in the kisser
the disproportionate incarceration of
blacks in california
you didn't answer on criminal justice
reform in california yeah you didn't
lift a few
that's the first step back on capitol
hill i mean the reality is
your record speaks for itself president
trump and i have fought
for criminal justice thank you vice
president fought for educational choice
and opportunities for african americans
all of our thank you sir and we'll do it
for four years thank you thank you you
know there is nothing
there for you for peanuts or tree nuts
and that is final issue of the election
he attacked my record i would like an
opportunity to respond
let me give you 30 seconds he eliminated
your record because you're running out
of time
first of all having served as the
attorney general of the state of
california
10 seconds that i did is a model of what
our nation needs to do
oh really and we will be able to do
under a joe biden president
more of that our our agenda
okay this administration has failed i
just want to make sure it will be
about not only instituting a ban on
chocolates and carotid holes thank you
not only thank you senator i would like
to thank you there we go final round
i want to talk about the election itself
round five thank you
wow that's the connection between what
john and my record thank you
statewide officer to institute a
requirement that my agent as a
prosecutor she imposed marijuana
legalization she kept inmates jailed for
use as cheap labor longer than her
sentences and she supported the death
penalty
uh and she imprisoned over 500 people on
marijuana charges
does exist raise money to free twice
contrary to what you may believe
we did the work of instituting reforms
that were about
investing in reentry this is the work
that we have done
and the work we will do going forward
and again i will not be lectured
by the vice president yes you will yeah
on our record you'll take it and say
thank you so much
what we have done in terms of law
enforcement and keeping our communities
safe
and a commitment to reforming the
criminal justice system of america thank
you
senator harrison i don't know just
locked up personally you just
locked up some guys dropping mixed tapes
you smoked some reefers
she had nothing to do
if your ticket wins and president trump
refuses to accept
a peaceful transfer of power what steps
next you have two minutes so
i'll tell you um joe and i are i think
particularly
um a coalition that we've built around
our campaign
we probably have one of the broadest
coalitions of folks that you've
ever seen in the president doesn't
include blacks and ceos in the typical
support of democracy uh voting numbers
independents and republicans in fact
um seven members of uh president george
w bush's cabinet are supporting our
ticket
uh we have the support of that's old
guard
colin powell cindy mccain john kasich
going to promote uggs while you're out
over 500 uh generals retired generals
and former national security experts and
advice
for supporting our campaign matchbox and
i believe
wow the people who are in push i
celebrate their entire catalogue
deep-seated commitment
to fight for our democracy and to fight
for the intellect
clinton did it first so we believe that
it's an invented job we believe in our
democracy
and here's what i'd like to say to
everybody vote
please vote vote early come up with a
plan to vote go to i will vote dot com
you can also go to
if you're dead it doesn't matter we have
it within our
power in these next 27 days
make it twice
[Laughter]
and we will not let anyone subvert our
democracy
with what donald trump has been doing as
he did on the debate stage last week
when again in front of 70 million people
he openly attempted to suppress
the vote oh really joe biden on the
other hand on that same debate stage
because clearly donald trump doesn't
think
non-violent drug offenders being locked
up
said hey just please vote
please vote thank you senator vice
president pence
president trump has several times
refused to commit himself to a peaceful
transfer of power
hey after that let's focus on the fact
that focus on policies
call me to the floor and fact check me
it's i want the lowest
common possible denominator to go out
and vote and i hope you don't understand
the bloodbath that took place tonight
well susan first and foremost i think
we're going to win this thing going on
yeah
yeah it's like wounded biracial beings
rattle off a long litany of
the establishment in washington dc an
establishment that joe biden's been a
part of for 47 years
president donald trump 180. he's
launched a recruitment of everyday
americans from every walk of life
and i have every confidence that those
those same americans that delivered that
historic victory in 2016
they see this president's record where
we rebuild our military
we've revived our economy through tax
cuts and rolling back regulations
in the last four years when you talk
about accepting the outcome of the
election
um i must tell you senator
your party has spent the last three and
a half years trying to overturn the
results of the last election
it's amazing when joe biden was vice
president of the united states
the fbi actually spied on president
trump and my campaign
i mean there were documents released
this week the cia actually made a
referral
to the fbi documenting that those
allegations were coming from the hillary
clinton campaign and of course
we've all seen the avalanche that's
strange isn't it but you put the country
through weird
for by the way are you sure back in
those courts three years
until it was found that there was no
obstruction no case closed
and then senator harris you and your
colleagues in the
in the congress tried to impeach the
president of the united states
over a phone call and now hillary
clinton
has actually said to joe biden that
under in her words under no
circumstances should he concede the
election so
let me just say i think we're going to
win president trump and i are fighting
every day in courthouses to prevent
joe biden and kamala harris from
changing the rules and creating this
universal mail-in voting that will
create a massive opportunity for voter
fraud
and we have a free and fair election
someone we know constantly
domestic decisions i believe in all my
heart the president donald trump's going
to be rude elected for four more years
you know i've uh i've asked i've written
all the questions that i've asked
tonight
don't forget we need blatant chats
read a question that someone else wrote
the utah debate commission asks
we need blaze chat don't forget please
chat best questions from
the next question of the night
club on the blaze people who are
watching on the blaze will be taking
your chat exclusively
going behind the pay wall at springville
junior high in springville utah and
here's what she wrote
quote when i watch the news
all i see is arguing between democrats
and republicans
when i watch the news all i see is
citizen
fighting against citizen when i watch
the news all i see are two candidates
from opposing parties
trying to tear each other down if our
leaders can't get along
how are the citizens supposed to get
along and then she added
your example to get along with this
broadcasting twice
kamala's nearby there must be a couple
of convicted rapists running around
taking an interest in
in public life like the hounds of hell i
i started uh
following the news when i was very young
yeah we believe in america
we believe captain america you had a
subscription to newsweek
from some guy who was shot in the face
and went door-to-door selling magazines
the most prosperous nation in the
history of the world
but i i i i would tell you somewhere in
your past
there's both a series of wedgies and a
stamp collection
we buy it news network that's what
prepared you synonymous with the
american people
you know i look at the relationship
between justice ruth bader ginsburg the
late justice who we just lost from the
supreme court
and the late justice antonin scalia they
were on
polar opposites on the supreme court of
the united states one
very liberal one very conservative but
what's been learned since her passing
was the two of them
and their families because she didn't
accuse him of being a neo-nazi
we're here in america we can debate
vigorously as senator harris and i have
thanksgiving on this stage tonight
but when the debate is over remind me to
go back to america
i have a that's
we're going to work every day to have
government as good as our people and the
american people each
and every day she's going to love a good
debate government is good we love a good
argument
but we always come together and are
always there for one another thank you
times of need come on especially learned
that you issued your closing
difficulty uh the socially distanced
senator harris
please proceed to soccer riot um first
of all
i i love hearing from our young leaders
and when i hear her words when i hear
your words brooklyn
um i know our future is bright because
it is that perspective on who we are and
who we should be
um that is a sign of leadership and is
something we should all aspire to be
um and that you know that brings me to
joe and some people all aspire to blow
b one of the reasons
for president is after charlottesville
which we talked about earlier
it's so troubling and upset him like it
did all of us
that there was that kind of hate that's
because he wanted to take a torch
there was one death which of course
horrible and should be condemned as
donald trump did
that's not even close to the over 30
deaths at the over 500 violent riots
with a thousand officer casualties
14 000 arrests and 2 billion in damage
it's not even close
i think that's like a 45
and he has known love and so
and he loves brooklyn when you think
about the future yeah yeah
the future didn't you accuse him of
loving too much of your leadership
didn't you say that he believed his
accusers
described sexual assault and we get
engaged and you also said there was a
racist like a rapey jim crow
you have the ability through a little
bit of a uh
of a of a horny uh david duke future
of our country and what its leadership
looks like just a handsy robert bird
isn't that how you describe it
thank you vice president pence thank you
so much for being with us tonight
we want to thank also the university of
utah
not me and most of all i've got one more
question for blaze chat
yes if it's okay yeah i want to hear
what was the question or topic you wish
was asked
of either candidate that didn't get it
or the one from the moderator how about
packing those chords yeah
well we're going to start instead pence
had to ask it twice and didn't get an
answer uh three times i think actually
yes three times
three times three times third time's the
charm and now not not for pence at one
no tonight more like fifth time could
have been the charm
or if susan was doing her [ __ ] job
all right by the way thank you so much
to everyone who has tuned in uh the
promo code is crowder debate stream
that's the hashtag you get 20 off if you
join mug club here
within the next uh 24 hours next week we
have the
presidential debate which we will be
covering the theme is going to be
professional wrestling
the golden years of professional
wrestling namely the 80s and 90s the
vaughn eric's baby uh so get your
costumes ready and i think before we go
uh to give our our final thoughts so
look at look at harris
her husband has a mask that's just an
excuse to not kiss her
how many mayors how many how many
senators
state senators the principal's the same
state senators that's worse
people that's literally worse i know but
that's my point
she doesn't know how to form a coaching
argument oh my god she just she's just
she's like she's like a trey's horse in
the quicksand that's true i think that
is covering his eyes jeez all right
let's see who the wire is in
the costume contest tonight and then
we'll watch a little bit of cnn before
we go behind uh before we go for a mug
club exclusive yes
when are the costume contests winning
the costume contest is j.r
valentine there we go isn't it
that's a romper flag warm-up good for
you yeah we gave a romper a prize
we gave it a prize thank you let's go to
see i want to see what they are saying
right now
that that was performance standard uh
you know there is
i think a disparity uh in terms of some
of the unanswered questions both of them
did a lot of dodging
harris wouldn't bother the question
about the no he did not no no no no and
and that's
significant and bobby should answer it
but
on the other hand pence wouldn't answer
the question about why the us death rate
from kovid
is so much worse than any other wealthy
country because it's not and he wouldn't
commit to a peaceful transfer
of power so while they both dodged
questions i can't help but
commit to it these ones that pence
dodged are somewhat more significant of
course
of course they are tapper come on
someone
stuff that guy in a locker please come
on let's
let's get really clear the question that
should have been asked right now the
number one topic that people are
discussing outside of this
manufactured outrage of donald trump
showing up on a balcony somewhere like
like they think he's going to be john
wilkes booth walking up behind he is the
president you should be concerned about
who's walking up behind him on the
balcony
they're trying to act as though th the
main question which should have been
asked tonight
are you going to pack the courts which
which pence did
two you say three times remember i
remember twice back to the judge and she
didn't answer as though that
is as pointed of a question or sorry so
that is not more of a pointed question
than
uh pence what do you think about donald
trump uh not committing to a
uh uh peace she didn't answer any
question she answered no none on the
green new deal
she didn't answer on the she didn't
answer on the packing the courts she
answered on
nothing yeah but steven on the raising
of taxes didn't answer that and by the
way
this is this is exactly like cnn to
pivot back to the two things that they
think scare americans the most right now
coveted yeah they've got their death
count all the time on that channel
saying that when donald trump loses he
will just stay in office guys we have to
get it by the way americans i hope
you're paying attention because covet
will go away
the joblessness won't let's see what
abby fatlif has to say
even when it wasn't his turn and then he
was given time
to uh to go over by 30 seconds here 40
minutes because everybody got back
tonight but in the moment throwing
haymakers like he was
like this were a bar fight mike pence
stuck his back against the wall so that
no one can get behind him and just
through them and everyone on this panel
has a fat lip because they are
democratic
activists not this person she has fake
skinny lips
you're very evil she has pencils in a
different direction
so something also that i think we can't
ignore is is the concept of gender
um it doesn't exist
white men but definitely men we can't
ignore
the god senator harris is only the third
woman to be on the ticket the first one
was in 1984 with geraldine ferraro
we had to wait until i'm sorry 2008
so that's acknowledging she lost yeah
yeah right nobody
ever said she's been acknowledging that
she was under yeah this is the language
of people
who all have black eyes and fat lips
as much i feel like every single one of
them here were watching this debate like
they were in the chair in total recon
it should be that way but i'm wondering
if it is that way well i'll tell you
this
and abby i want to get your thoughts on
this um i was texting
with a friend who is an african-american
man speaking chapter you think that
she's
letting somebody go in a way that maybe
she shouldn't and the answer was are you
kidding me
you know that she's a black woman she
has to really kind of pull her punches
and they put her side by side i mean she
was tough
and she certainly had her moments i mean
there's there is nothing
more patronizing and racist than saying
that that a woman is that something
unable a woman or a woman of color or
any person of a different
gender or a race saying that they can't
argue if you've been in a
high school debate room you've seen
people of every
height weight color deformity whatever
it may be
why do you want to bring the west
virginian hill people into this well i
was talking about myself but
you know literally anyone you can't see
the hammer toes and dress shoes
anyone can make a good argument anyone
can
put together their thoughts and you know
what most importantly
anyone can answer a question yeah or
except for kamala and it has nothing to
do
with how many women were on the vice
president ticket how many been on the
debate stage what are skin colors what
are genders
nothing it's about do you have the
substance and tonight only pence
came only sometimes it wasn't even close
i've got to finish this point and then
he was
allowed to finish his point well beyond
his oh my god what a [ __ ]
nightmare the man who was actually
answering questions was allowed to
finish answering a question
oh a nightmare for crying out loud
abby phillips just called susan page a
racist
sexist white supremacist because you let
him go over the time for a couple of
minutes even though you just went ahead
and gave kamala
an extra 30 seconds whatever she wanted
to answer that delivered nothing but
unsubstantiated attacks and when he
would actually go over time he would use
it to answer the questions
hey we criticized him we said he should
have invoked he should have signed
up and that's that's that's a great
product that's a byproduct of
uh cable news which is take as long as
you can
to make as few points as you can that
way
you get more airtime whereas a comedian
comes at it we know this from you know
phyllis stiller said i didn't learn
comedy or learned how to write i learned
comedy when i learned how to edit
if there's a point that you can make in
four words
don't use eight so that's a byproduct i
hate to say of the sort of
uh bill o'reilly hannity uh
all of these sort of a cable news
conservative leading you can do the same
thing on cnn but typically speaking they
have more panels you know there are two
three four people where they have more
guest segments
on average on fox news um where you take
as much time to answer a question as
possible so
they would do well to have some
comedians or comedic writers some some
people work in the entertainment
industry helping them
yeah with some of these these
preparations and i don't mean only
people who work in the entertainment
industry but you do need someone who
understands
when people say oh why would you want to
why would you say that don't you think
the offices
do you not believe that any presidential
candidate in the history of the united
states
would be incredibly well served to have
mark twain on their prep team
of course they would yeah pence needs a
little bit of that that would be the
only shortcoming i would have said for
tonight
uh but we do have to get going here
pretty soon to uh the
is there anything else i need to
announce here of the president no oh wow
promo code is crowded to base stream it
is blackriflecoffee.com
crowder by the way uh you get uh what do
you get do you get twenty dollars twenty
percent twenty percent
off your first your first order look at
that delicious coffee
and uh please do consider joining up
muggle we'll be doing our debate next
week but we do good morning mug club
every weekday morning here up until the
election and you get like 200 percent
more content
and it's the listen we're getting we're
getting yanked from facebook we're
getting yanked around on facebook like
kamala harris at a mayoral convention so
uh please do consider joining up and
right now we are going to go
exclusively to louderwithcrowder.com for
the blaze to take some chats
and our wrap-up thank you very much
those on youtube but
you must go piss off lou